Damn ! Les gens c'est Tibo InShape. En fait c'est Fabien Olicard, c'était encore un prank...!
Ouais mais je vais aller là bas, comme ça on aura plus de lumière pour faire un nouveau casse tête. C'est celui ci
Parce que oui c'est pas parce qu'on est au mois d'août que les mercredis matins il n'y a pas un nouveau casse-tête à 6H00 du matin sur la chaîne.
Je suis ravi puisque je vois vraiment que ça vous plaît aussi bien les casses-têtes sur la chaîne YouTube que sur mon Instagram.
Après les gros plans que je vous fais,
n'hésitez pas à les voir si vous n'avez pas vu.
Les deux vidéos se complètent toujours.
Et tant que j'y suis, merci à ceux qui m'envoient des photos sur Instagram
de eux à la plage ou en vacances en train de lire mon deuxième livre.
Celui là !
Bah c'est trop cool, voilà je suis ravi qu'il vous plaise autant que le premier. C'était le but !
Si vous l'avez pas je vous mets le lien dans la description.
Ce casse-tête à un petit peu la forme d'un fruit et c'est sûrement pour ça qu'ils l'ont appelé "le casse-tête citron".
Parce que ça à un petit peu l'air d'un citron, ça ce serait le corps du fruit et ici au dessus on aurait la tige, alors
en l'osculptant rapidement on se rend compte qu'il y a trois parties distinctes c'est-à-dire, ce qui représente la tige
est clairement composé de deux parties reliées par une boule et le corps c'est cette partie là qui est unique et complètement solidaire.
C'est un casse-tête "intermédiaire +"et je comprends le fait qu'il soit intermédiaire plus parce qu'on comprend tout de suite le but
il faut défaire les trois parties et faut être capable de les refaire derrière c'est le but des casse-têtes
le défaire complètement, étape une
le refaire complémentent,  étape deux
c'est ce qui sert à prouver aussi qu'on a compris le mécanisme du casse tête
mais de la manière dont a été faite la partie solidaire avec les rainures qu'on voit ici
ici, ici, ici, on se rend bien compte qu'il va y avoir un chemin à parcourir pour pouvoir le sortir.
Ce qui effectivement peut paraître très simple
ou va peut-être me paraître très dur, ça on ne sait jamais à chaque fois comment commencent ces vidéos. En tout cas c'est la première fois que
je vois un casse-tête qui ressemble à un aliment, là en l'occurrence un fruit et je trouve ça
particulièrement stylé c'est pour ça que je l'ai pris d'ailleurs, c'est qu'il m'a beaucoup plu quand je le vois j'aime bien l'idée,
j'aime bien le concept parce que ces deux tiges là sont attachées par une boule,
je comprends pas tout à fait le système encore mais j'ai l'impression qu'il y a une barre qui sort de celui là donc ce serait
la tige avec la barre qui rentre dans cette tige là, qui elle a un trou pour recevoir la tige c'est le principe de l'emboîtement
Pourquoi on est tous en train de se marrer derrière nos écrans ? Je ne sais pas ! Donc ouais
j'aime bien le principe et je le trouve même très joli le travail du métal est plutôt bien fait
et donc c'est parti on va essayer de le défaire.
Donc,
je pense déjà,
que c'est impossible de faire passer les deux tiges par le même chemin.
Je pense qu'il faut qu'ils aient deux chemins opposés en fait, mais assez logiquement.
Ok donc si ça c'est sa position initiale
où ici il butte à cause de la boule, et ici il est en butte à cause de la tige.
et si on le pivote de 90 degrés,
il perd facilement, là pour le coup les tiges arrivent à se séparer une fois.
Donc en fait ça va être ça, c'est de trouver... Ah oui ! D'accord ok.
mais même s'ils sont séparés une fois je peux pas libérer réellement la tige du trou.
Je ne sais pas si je suis bien clair. Je vous ferai des gros plans de tout ça aussi sur Instagram.
Je pense que je vais le cracker assez facilement, du coup je me demande si je vais pas vous faire
l'inverse de ce que je fais d'habitude ; à savoir essayer de faire tout le chemin dans ma tête pour le cracker
et essayer de le faire après d'un coup sans chercher. Qu'est ce que vous en pensez ? Je vous mets un sondage ici et vous me dites.
Par contre le problème c'est que
c'est que je peux pas lire le résultat du sondage... je vais essayer de pressentir le résultat du sondage
Ok on fait ça, ça marche. Donc, deux parties... qui peuvent pivoter à chaque fois, le but c'est de virer ça et de pouvoir les...
Ok, je pense que c'est bon, j'ai juste un
doute sur la fin je n'arrive pas bien à voir s'il va falloir que je passe tout par là, ou seulement l'un des deux.
Du coup je me le tente. Donc quart de tour 90°...
On ouvre, on ouvre...
Quart de tour 90 degrés, on passe, on passe... quart de tour 90 degrés ici,
180,
on sort lui,
puis...
pour lui on fait clac... clac.... clac... clac...
Boum ! C'est craqué !
C'est craqué, est-ce que ça a été cracké ?
Alors là vous vous dites peut-être dans l'espace commentaire que il était pas si difficile que ça.
Je suis d'accord !
"Intermédiaire +"...
Je dirais plutôt "intermédiaire moins", voire "moyen"... (niveau de difficulté)
Assez moyen, mais ça c'est plutôt cool quand vous avez un casse tête,
un "casse-crâne" comme il y en a qui disent, que vous pressentez moyen. Vous pouvez essayer de vous challenger comme ça
en vous disant: "Ok, j'essaye de faire tout le parcours en visualisation 3D dans ma tête et après j'essaie de le faire une fois
sans m'arrêter une seule fois et sans erreur." Du coup je suis assez content de m'être donné ce défi là parce que je crois que
j'aurais été déçu
je sais même pas si j'aurais mis la vidéo si j'avais trouvé ça aussi rapidement, mais on n'a fini que la première étape.
Donc il faut finir la deuxième étape. En vrai c'est pas mal parce que c'est assez joli en terme de symétrie et tout.
Ah oui voilà j'étais en train d'essayer de me rappeler comment était la position initiale c'est ça qui est dur dans les casses têtes !
C'est vraiment quelle était la position initiale, la boule était là et l'autre était là.
Je pense que pour le remettre, ce sera pas la même quand même. Ça me paraît plus malin d'essayer de commencer par lui
Et du coup lui je vais le remettre ici...
Donc lui... Ah ben non ça ne marche pas mon histoire... Je vais le remettre ici.
Comme ça lui, je le rentre là.
Je pense qu'il faut commencer par les emboîter dès le départ.
Et on retrouve... Ah non ça ne marche pas mon truc. Le mec a cru qu'il avait tout compris mais il a juste cru qu'il avait tout compris en fait...
Non, ça va pas mon histoire... il faut forcément que ça, ça commence comme ça.
Mais si je le mets là, à ce moment là...
à ce moment là tu vois, ça ne pourra pas marcher pour aller le remettre entièrement.
Parce que si je pars des deux en même temps, ça peut être une bonne technique...
Oui !!!
Clac,
euh... ah je peux pas clac là
Clac, Clac,
Clac,
Et là à 180...
Clac
clac
et nous avons un citron merveilleusement refait !
Comme disait Baracuda: "J'adore lorsqu'un plan se déroule sans accroc."
C'est vrai, et c'était pas barracuda d'ailleurs qui disait ça c'était Hannibal.
Les belles années 80-90... Bon, écoute super cool ! Je suis trop content !
Je vais le garder, je le ferai pas souvent mais ça c'est un
casse tête je ne pense que je vais pas mal offrir,
soit aux fans de casse-têtes parce que le côté citron et chemins étaient assez intéressant,
le côté de pouvoir se défier en se challengeant à l'avant a essayé de le faire en 3D
et je l'offrirai aussi à des gens qui veulent débuter en casse-têtes parce que du coup ce n'est pas impossible à résoudre,
même si tu n'as pas compris comment tu l'as résolu, tu peux t'entraîner pour comprendre la mécanique de résolution.
Beaucoup de fois le mot "résoudre" conjugués de plein de manières différentes ça fait plaisir !
La semaine prochaine par contre ce sera moins de la rigolade, parce qu'on va prendre un casse-tête de
difficulté extrême mercredi prochain à 6H00 sur la chaîne.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner si ce n'est pas fait. D'activer la cloche, de liker cette vidéo si elle vous a plu.
Cette vidéo était paru sur Dailymotion un petit peu en avance, oui sur ma chaîne secondaire sur Dailymotion si tu veux voir il y a le lien dans la description.
Merci et à très bientôt !
Ciao !